1943
detailed information from the manhattan
project was stolen from los
alamos by the russian spy known as
perseus
1968 the vietnam war
vietcon soldiers orchestrated by perseus
attempted to steal an american-made
nuclear bomb from a u.s
firebase five days ago
while on a mission we acquired intel
that perseus is in play again
and planning an attack on the west
[Music]
perseus the cia's analysts consider him
to be the single
largest threat to the free world
mr hudson we're all aware of perseus
we're also aware he's more myth than
fact i mean
personally i think he's nothing more
than the russian boogeyman
general hague allow me to introduce the
man
as soon as the responder c.i.a
clandestine special officer russell
adler
he's one of the few people even come
close to capturing percy's
uh mr adler why should we take this
perseus threat seriously you don't have
to sir
yeah but then a lot of innocent people
are gonna die why do you say that
sir every time perseus has come into
play it shifted the balance of the cold
war
after 13 years of silence if he's active
something big
is gonna happen something that will
affect the free world
[Music]
mr president sir mr president mr
president this is
jason hudson and russell i know their
names
who do you think approved their last
mission
is the threat real yes sir we believe it
is
can you stop perseus we can sir i've
already submitted the requisition for my
team
sir their requests are highly irregular
most likely illegal if the press gets
old what the hell are you talking about
you know who we are every mission we go
on is illegal
sergeant woods plausible deniability is
the backbone of our work
now we're talking about preventing an
attack on the free men and women of the
world
give mr adler whatever he wants
gentlemen
you've been given an important task
protecting our very way of life from a
great evil
there is no higher duty there is no
higher honor
and while few people will know of your
struggles
rest assured the entire free world
will benefit i know you won't fail us
pre-order digital copy and get early
access to the open beta and instant
access to the woods operator pack in
modern warfare including warzone